[Music]
you can stay with me
when it came to music
[Music]
nothing would mean more to me than for
us to sing
together again so you guys were like a
duo she was also the love of my life
but i never told her how i felt
all my love i put it into a song
you spent your life making me lose
he will he must deliver this song to
mark that
she needs to know that i love her here i
come
[Music]
martha needs to hear this song and i'm
gonna get you there
get in my
the bag for love is han no
go to town his name's vevo use the
possum
gaby that's a pikachu aka the honey bear
[Music]
you can't stop now
what are you gonna do now i don't know
but sometimes you gotta improvise
and she missed
[Music]
lives forever in your heart
you